oh i want to play stafford
i'll play a french someone was saying
something about french earlier
opponents bedazzled by my
by my french
okay so
i don't usually play the french
i think of all my years in competitive
tournament chess
i've played the french twice
once in this pan american collegiate
championship
um it was actually my first pan am i was
in the final round
i played it with
some decent success against another i am
got a winning position
eventually drew
my other time playing the french was
against a wonderliang
and he beat me
so
i probably played the french
a few times on stream
people have bribed me
ooh okay exchange variation time
exchange variation a lot of people just
don't like because it's symmetrical but
there are ways to play aggressively
there's also ways to not gambit and
still play aggressively so
i think the philosophy if you're a
french player and like goes for exchange
variation
it means that
you you can pretty
quickly equalize and then try and
outplay the opponent
a bit later
um
so i've actually played this
i played this position as white
and the move i usually
so the move
gives me the most troubles is bishop d6
and there is a line uh c4 and then
knight f6
i think is one of the main lines
and depending on white plays i might
i might go for a setup where i castle
queenside there should be five
okay let's play this
bishop e5 is a small inaccuracy
it's typically seen in like beginner
chess where you see a check you give a
check
but it only helps opponent improve the
position
now i'll play knight e7
so my plan is to play bishop g4 knight
here queen here
and then decide which way i want to
castle
[Music]
now there are cases and some openings
where bishop b5 is played to provoke c6
because maybe there's some argument like
it takes away the c6 square for the
knight
but i don't think that's really the case
um in this opening
i'll play off six
you can start with this too
[Music]
i'll start with this
a little bit more flexible
yeah f6 is very typical especially if i
want to launch a kingside attack
um because if i put the king on the
queen side then my pawns can get rolling
it's paradoxical i started playing in
december 2020. just hit 1800 plus in
rapidonchess.com last week
i want to thank you for all of your
content it has been super instructive
and given me the opportunity to grow at
an awesome rate
my pleasure oh thanks so much for the
thousand bits hope you can keep it up
that's nice to hear
1800 plus rapidonchest.com
i think that's equivalent to like 2000
plus only chess
december 2020 was
less than a year ago
it's always cool to hear people like
who have taken up the game within the
last like year like very recently
making big climbs
okay so i have the
battery um i'm still staying flexible
like there there is a universe where
maybe i'll castle
king side
but probably not
guess if white plays this move
makes things a little bit tricky
or mixing scary on the queen side but
i'll figure it out
hey it's toggy what's up doggy
oh tagging saying hello i am rosen hello
chat hello pam
a vip pam
okay so i i was threatening bishop takes
h2 which
my opponent probably saw
the knight was pinned
so now there's tension between the
bishops
um
debating like i might want to take
white would like to take back with the
h-pawn
and then i just maintain the pin there
would be no h3 and i have the potential
to
push the h pawn open the file
and usually this structure is completely
fine for a white it kind of brings the h
pawn closer to the center
now the one drawback i'm seeing
is if takes takes h5
there's rookie one
pinning my knight and tying down my king
to defending the knights
and probably planning queen e2
so
it turns me off a little bit from this
line
it takes takes if i castle
there's still rookie one
[Music]
that's a question what i'm doing with my
knight
put the rook on e8
the other option is just a castle right
away
and keep the option open of knight g6 to
f4
i think i'll do that actually
leave the tension
because if white takes and i
um
i just improved the queen
and white has lost a lot of time like
moving the bishop and then just trading
it off
so okay carlson queen side
yeah i'm liking the slower pace it's
nice uh
nice difference compared to playing the
blitzen bullet that i usually do
so b3
b3
it's a little bit mysterious i think
white wants to play this move
what i mean if white wants to play c4 it
probably should have been played right
away
because now i have an extra tempo to
do something
but the question is what to do
this move is still on my radar
knife f4 could
be appealing
i'm just calculating some lines like
imagine knight g6 c4 knight f4 attacking
the bishop
and after trade trade i'm hitting
the h pawn still
if g3 i can take take and win the knight
yeah i like this better because if i
play h5 then i like slow chicks i can't
really do this
because i'm the bishop um bishop just
prevents the knight from coming here
also if i take take and knight g6 and
the pawn restricts my knight
so
[Music]
i'll start with this
oh i like your username make out makeup
i like your substrate too subbing for 14
months
it's pretty clear what my intentions are
in this position with offsets like
castling um
a lot of
what it comes down to is who can attack
quicker
so
[Music]
i think black is already in like better
shape i have the pin
i have this
potential
maybe after i play an f4 i can start
swarming the pawns
and white's a bit slower like c4 i can
kind of just ignore it
carry on with my own way
yeah the tea is very good thanks again
robert e
i put some
[Music]
some honey in it some
mana floral manuka honey
use my electric whisk thing to stir it
yeah and uh
i think it's meant to be hot that i made
at least
okay so this is all part of the
calculation
um
oh it's under some pressure
oh
i just missed this move
i may have just missed this move
i was only calculating this assuming
white would have to defend against the
threat
but that's
a very logical counter-attack
and now i'm inclined to sack but
stacking's probably not good
i probably just have to move back which
is
kind of unfortunate
the good news after bishop f8
white can't attack the knight again
and i'll be ready to play g5
i just have to deal with it
okay
so yeah if i saw c5 coming
[Music]
maybe i would have played like bishop f4
i should have left the f4 square open
what to do
oh why not bishop e7 if bishop b7
i didn't want my
i didn't want to put my bishop
on a square that's not defended
so like rookie one would hit it and
um
maybe there's some other justification
after this i can redevelop it to g7
because it's kind of dead on this
diagonal
okay time for g5
probably unless there's something else i
mean the bishop's still not defended
i guess i should calculate this move
and then h3
we trade
[Music]
love to make h5 work but after h3
doesn't seem so good
okay g5
imagine g5 b5 i have queen a5
and then there's takes takes
takes takes
it still looks like a fight okay let's
play g5
there's a question can i berserk in this
i could
um now it's too late you have to
berserk at the beginning of the game
um
i think the rule for this tournament at
least for me is not to berserk
unless my opponent beserks
oh and knight takes bishop be an option
it's not the move i want to play um
i don't want to give away my queen
i might have to eventually but i'm going
to hold off for now
so queen a4 hitting my pawn
and there's this move
also b5 is interesting
if on passant
and i take and hit the queen
actually b5 looks kind of nice
and there's just queen b3
although okay let's imagine
b5
if takes takes i'm happy because then my
bishop can redevelop
it should be okay
if queen b3
idea would be
probably be to play
a6 with a4 here
it's not pleasant but i'll play b5
and this does leave room for white to go
wrong in different ways
okay so this is what i was kind of
hoping for
i mean things are about to get kind of
messy
but thankfully okay i have initiative
against the queen
white could check me in different ways
but then king b8 redeveloped the bishop
this pawn looks kind of weak
worst case scenario i have this or this
best case scenario
i win the lottery
okay king b8s really only move
oh queen still attacked
maybe white will forget
okay white didn't forget now the pawns
are ready to roll
so what to do
you know i i have
like different plans it's actually kind
of a rich position
there's bishop d6
h5
kind of like the prospect of h5
just wanna
start making threats against the king's
side
[Music]
white's really tempting me to
sack stocking might be playable actually
like bishop here oh no my bishop takes
and then knight h2 i'm not winning
immediately but
something like
just a long-term pressure against the
diagonal like queen h7
it looks fun
yeah let's do it
so
it's going back to
who said this earlier something about
whenever i don't play gambit
it still ultimately turns into a gambit
but this this is a sacrifice again this
is the stream title
referring to gambits refers to opening
gambits
gampix oh thanks for the gambit i
appreciate that
those are my some of my favorite types
of
bits i guess
so with all the side whites oh white
doesn't have to take but white took okay
so i'll take back
oh there's kind of a cool line actually
okay i should have calculated like all
of this beforehand
but the cool line is rook takes h2
stacking even more material
i'm probably just gonna go into a tank
here
um
rogue h2 if king h2 rogeche king here
here
there's f3
but then queen h1 king f2 queen g2 i won
the bishop it should be winning
so rook h2 assume bishop h2
knight e2 oh no my knight
oh no white's bishop here and then here
and the bishop g4 is really nice move
bishop g1 with queen h2 mate
so one more time takes takes knight e2
bishop e2
[Music]
there's also king h1 but probably rocket
shape there
yeah the queen can't really defend
because my bishop controls g3
okay so
rook h2 here
no rook h2 uh bishop h2
knight e2 bishop e2 bishop h2 king h1
rogue h8
how does white defend probably g3
and then i have queen h7
uh threatening made in two
i don't see how white defends that
i mean there's like queen d3 or bishop
d3 to attack my queen
but then queen h3
i'm just hugging the king
king g2 queen h3
i think i'd do it
right h2
case scenario i lose and learn learn
from my lessons
wait i missed uh there's one line takes
takes here
you're
oh i never has time to take the bishop
in that line okay let's take
okay we're having some fun here
so it looks reckless but
and this this is based on calculation
if this were a blitz game i would have
to take without calculating or maybe
play something else but
um
i'm just realizing white doesn't have to
actually take
i am threatening to take on g2 so
okay so now the continuation is 92.
white has two legal moves
i didn't really spend so much time on
that
i assumed taking with transpose but now
i'm realizing rook h8 might just
be completely winning
or even even this move
a threatening mate
yeah queen
how does light defend
yay
rookies cranny subbing with prime
this is just completely winning i think
there is f4 okay so f4
but then g3
oh but then knight f3 what is this
f4 i mean onpo swamp and then takes
i'm taking time here because after it
takes
knight takes rook hey it looks winning
within queen h3
maybe i just take on d4 in that line
oh that's actually nice
so line uh queen h7 f4
abstracting my bishop and then i take on
passant
knight takes and then knight takes d4
attacking the queen
and trying to remove the guard
that should be winning
okay
my night's still hanging
but white doesn't have time to take it
and now
yeah now i have this move
should get the job done
because there's no
there's no counter checks
if this it's mates
might prolong the meat
it's not okay
that was nice
got some uh
unexpected attack that game
i mean i missed c5 it looked like white
was attacking me but things turned
around really quickly
um
i guess i i got initiative here
and then started making threats here
i took the bishop
and the fact that h5 opened was really
really nice
was this a sound sacrifice
hey it was
so bishop
the engine says bishop d6 is one of the
best moves
much more fun than bishop c8
and then apparently it was really bad
for light to take
because after it takes
wow rick8 shoe's a only winning move too
yeah i think initially i was thinking
also queen h7 is some idea but
this is just way more forcing takes and
92 only winning
[Music]
i managed to find this pretty direct
sequence
and yeah the line i was calculating was
f4
because initially i want to take take
and this looks like mate
but uh the queen can block so
um
oh engine just likes this move
i was thinking here and then
knight f3
oh this is winning
i guess queen h3 then still winning
yeah i was thinking i would on poisson
which is also
wait oh unfortunate's not winning
wait a minute
what was i thinking
oh yeah i was thinking on the song x-men
takes
ah queen d3 hitting my queen
okay good thing that didn't happen
i would have taken my time but then i
would have had like a moral dilemma
whether it's on passant or not
i'll put someone give the game away
anyway if this goes on youtube that was
a fun game hope people enjoy that
i did kind of go wrong in the opening
allowing c5 and that f4 was a bad move
but
that's nice finish